we begin this morning with the document
that's deepening division in Washington
and raising the stakes of the Russia
investigation Republicans on the House
Intelligence Committee released a memo
authored by Chairman Devin Nunez despite
strong objections from the FBI Justice
Department and Democrats on the
committee it accuses the FBI and Justice
Department leaders of abusing their
powers to spy on a former Trump campaign
adviser suspected of working for the
Russian government the document which
includes information Declassified by the
White House is intensifying the
increasingly partisan battle over Russia
and its role in our presidential
election Errol Barnett is with the
president in West Palm Beach
Erol good morning good morning president
Trump ignored warning signs from the FBI
deciding instead it is in his best
interests to release this Republican
authored memo which effectively raises a
cloud of doubt and suspicion over one
aspect of the special counsels Russia
investigation I think it's a disgrace
hours before departing Washington's
President Trump made clear his
frustration with the FBI's handling of
the Russia investigation a lot of people
should be ashamed of themselves and much
worse than that
illustrating his point mr. Trump
approved the release of a full-page memo
from Republicans on the House
Intelligence Committee it claims before
the 2016 election FBI agents relied on a
politically motivated dossier compiled
by former British spy Christopher Steele
in seeking permission to monitor Trump
campaign advisor caught a page the memo
says when agents went before a secret
FISA Court Judge they did not mention
Steele was working on behalf of and paid
by the DNC and Clinton campaign they
would have never received a warrant
without the dossier Devon Nunez the
Republican chairman of the Intel
committee whose team drafted the memo
defended its release we had to take all
of this information and reduce it down
into into a summary with just the
pertinent facts about the FISA abuse the
only area that I am familiar with that
we left out would be the the history of
Carter pay
Adam Schiff the top Democrat on the
committee said the court was told stills
work was likely politically motivated
this wasn't about oversight this is
about telling a political story that's
helpful to the president about telling a
political story that's designed to
injure the work of the special counsel
and discredited the FBI opposed the
memos release citing grave concerns
about material emissions of fact for
example FBI agents knew Russians
recording Carter page three years before
the dossier was written fide FBI
director James Comey called the memo
dishonest and misleading saying it
destroyed trust within the intelligence
community the release of this memo was
going to do some very serious damage
former director of the CIA Leon Panetta
echoed that sentiment the president in
the Congress I now have a position of
distrust with the Justice Department and
the FBI amid the turmoil President Trump
refused to vocalize his opinion of the
man effectively in charge of the Russian
investigation Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein you figured that one out
now the White House says President Trump
made this decision with input from his
national security team and members of
the intelligence community for whom he
has great respect they tell us meanwhile
Democrats on that same committee have
their own memo it is still waiting for
declassification Anthony Errol Barnett
in West Palm Beach Thank You Errol